come on that powerful PAH you were gonna
go on a peach are you my son now
chromatic oh the hunch thing you do as
you healthy such a small face what was
it supposed to be you know it's a
compliment it's a good thing compliment
um it means your proportion is really
good oh cool thanks Claire does that no
that makes my face Church could use a
little more can you go more more and
more more MORE all right all right how's
this
that's I can't even see you back there
all right
[Music]
yeah I'm have it nice to meet you Matt
Matt hold are you man
24 24 so magnitude sorry born in 1992 oh
yeah yeah yeah I'm older than you okay
hey uh can use some water on the way
sure thank you oh hey can you uh give
him some napkins yeah thanks yo Matt can
you give some snacks I got a deadline
man I gotta finish this I'm sorry
serious what I'm older so I have
everything set for our 22nd fifty
hundred days and two hundred a
anniversary a second day I never forget
how many celebrations are we gonna have
here as many as possible 22nd he's a
must
yeah I just I just never heard of a 22nd
is it too much no I made too much no no
no no no let's do a 23rd day anniversary
- how about that sounds perfect
[Music]
yo Evan what's up dick yo band that was
that it's called daddy
never heard of it and Rona's what having
is what is this 2015 wake up man
and he never texts me first easy blood
type aid
why would I knew his blood type how
could you not know his blood type it
says everything about his personality
it does mm-hmm so there's only four
personalities that's not right is it
[Music]
one odd for team ends in a while we'll
wondering we are to live in young things
are
[Music]